ce la fai a prendere il martello zio
prima che ecco perché no no madonna mia
quanto trash questa scena santo iddio a
questa operazione di lusso prevede anche
un taglio i capelli questo è il cuore di
trump
oh cazzo è quella è una collana che le
regalo sempre io veramente siamo di
nuovo su questa merda della tutti
ragazzi e benvenuto che sono video sono
vari geni ed oggi siamo tornati su sorge
un simulator ragazzi allora era da una
vita ma veramente da una vita che non
facevo videogame considerando il fatto
che non mi ricordo come si muove la mano
ma mi ricordo che avevo cristo nato che
la metà basta perché mi si è appena
suicidato l'orologio da polso
[Musica]
ho voluto rigiocare a star john
simulator x che hanno inserito una nuova
modalità che è quella di che è successo
a ok è già partito niente già partita
hanno inserito la nuova modalità che
consiste nell'operare donald trump
giuro che tu devi operare donald trump
sul sergio è un simulatore di fare un
trapianto di cuore a donald trump
nel senso che io gli devo trapiantare un
cuore d'oro un cuore di pietra o che
quindi devo levare il cuore che c'è e
metterli un cuore un cuore di pietra che
bello trump ha descritto in basso
breaking news dalla serie proprio stanno
operando donald trump sarà il dottore in
grado di salvargli la vita è ovvio mica
come solo professionale io che ho preso
al naso
vuoi avere un'anteprima del mio voto per
le elezioni caro trump
vabbè basta cerchiamo di capire chi sono
un regalo poiché c'è una bistecca
qual è il motivo va bene signor trump
siccome questa qua e una sala operatoria
molto di lusso per lei e l'abbiamo
riservata una bella bistecca di media
cottura come lei preferisce buon
appetito
vediamo di fare questo trapianto come si
deve posso usare un po mark d'oro perché
d'oro a perché lui e donando trump è
giusto le cose devono essere di lusso
devo devo incidere ecco devo cazzo
ok perfetto effettuato questa operazione
con la massima sensibilità l'ha sentito
niente
perfetto ecco ragazzi e questo ve lo
spiega il dottor favi se il paziente non
risponde quando fate delle domande
significa che indubbiamente sta bene
sono ve lo direbbe questo qua è il suo
si sa mai se lo vendo su ebay ci fasci
big money c'è anche il prezzo
dell'operazione 836 mila dollari la
madonna se glielo spalmi in faccia vale
di più ti piace vodka trump oh cazzo non
scherzava signor trump ecco bravo apra
la bocca perfetto per quanto trash
questa scena santo iddio assente quando
ho sentito il profumo di vodka
spalancato la bocca dove è in tutto
questo sta morendo tanto quindi io direi
è la madonna osserva perché è va bene
questa operazione di lusso prevede anche
un taglio i capelli quindi stia
tranquillo si rilassi che procedono a
non vorreste vedere questa cosa quindi
non me la faccio vedere
va bè ragazzi proviamo a farlo serio
adesso se non lo so e se riesco perché
da una vita che sono fuori allenamento
consorzio già era difficile ai tempi
senti è come il bambino col ciuccio
prendi quello che vuoi è il martello per
scassare non c'è più niente
eccolo quella che è presa bella solida
che ce la fai a prendere il martello zio
prima che ecco perché no no madonna mia
che deficente posso usare questo per
staccarli le ossa ha sì sì posso kay ce
l'ho fatta ragazzi sto togliendo non so
neanche come ma veramente esistono dei
laser davvero di non riuscire no credo
di aver ucciso l'infermiera nell'altra
sala ragazzo ne sono sicuro non c'e la
siringa per fermare le metto la pensava
sarebbe la siringa rigorosamente con
l'ago d'oro perché sono
bene per fermare l'emorragia ok per mara
ma cazzo che l'ha aumentata la come
parlare vero e non funziona e tarocca il
signor trump non sia lago d'oro non
serve un cazzo in teoria doveva fermare
l'emorragia non aumentarla vabbè non
importa proviamoci lo stesso mai può
fare veloce sennò trump e mi dispiace se
devo buttare i suoi organi che vorranno
un sacco di soldi perché la mano mi si è
rimpicciolito non importa vai vai veloce
prendi sto [ __ ] organo dempre forza
crepare sto cristiana e vabbè affanculo
nel frattempo prima che crepi mi prendo
il fegato non riesco a prendere le cose
di mortacci sua e li mortacci veramente
crepa dove se mi facessi favore di
perfetta sì ma sto madonna quanto sei
monco amiche ma radici come lo stai
tenendo operazione chirurgica della
massima importanza tiene il martello
così come se fosse una clip 1600
millilitri di sangue velocissimo prendi
stop allora che proprio di questo
polmone frate qual è il problema
ho mica questo qua lo vendo al doppio
regalerà in estraibile a zio e annusa
perfetto
adesso rinnoviamo questo coso che
probabilmente un pokémon infermiera mi
passi il telefono che devo controllare
se su pokemon gol ci sono pokémon in
questa stanza ma come ha fatto
incastrarsi li porca [ __ ] perfetto
altro mi spiegate con che fisica sta
tenendo sto coso spiegano abbia fatta
vai veloce in cdc di bravo zio e gioia
che mi dai perfetto vai effetto o no
l'orologio è lei una feature che glielo
regalo fa parte dell'operazione se non
mi muovo ragazzi costo mischia perfetto
sono fatta non solo rimpiazzarlo questo
è il cuore di trump oh cazzo è quella è
una collana che le regala sempre io
aprii borja [ __ ] già fatta e
prendiamo il cuore d'oro
ok incitiamo posizioniamo la veloce
veloce perché ci sta musica di
sottofondo spiegato benché forzosi in
town swiss medical center hospital ray
minuti e 24 di operazione perfetto
riconcilia con gaga e la è la cosa più
trash ma veramente più trash che io
abbia mai fatto in sto gioco è
bellissimo va bene mi fa piacere questo
gioco ogni tanto se ne esca queste
cagate comunque la casuali
mi è piaciuto spero sia stato di lezione
per tutti quanti voi perché ovviamente
questa è una lezione di di chirurgia
avanzata se avete bisogno di altri
tutorial guardati miei primi video su
serge simulator che esplicano come
effettuare un vero trapianto di cuore di
reni di pokémon vedrà che a soli spero
che vi sia piaciuto e cosa se vi è
piaciuto mentre ero mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e come ha invitato a
fare iscrizione sensore si fischetti ci
davano prossimo vito bella ragazza è
bella trump sarà sicuramente
contentissimo ma [ __ ]